este es el brave commander un barco con
un nombre muy apropiado ya que es el
primero en llevar ayuda alimentaria
fuera de ucrania desde que comenzó la
guerra la misión del programa mundial de
alimentos de la onu es entregar
cargamento de trigo a las comunidades
afectadas por el hambre en áfrica este
barco llevará a 23 mil toneladas
métricas de trigo a la gente hambrienta
de etiopía gente que está literalmente
al borde de la hambruna estamos muy
contentos de que este sea el primer
barco que sale de este puerto y que un
barco humanitario esté realmente
liderando el camino building weigh tras
abandonar el puerto de piso de mí el
martes el carguero se dirigió a turquía
donde se someterá a inspecciones antes
de partir hacia yibutí un viaje que fue
posible gracias a un acuerdo para
levantar el bloqueo ruso de los puertos
ucranianos el tratado para el paso
seguro por las aguas cargadas de minas
el mar negro se firmó en julio desde
entonces dos docenas de barcos han
salido de ucrania
muchos de ellos cargados de maíz
almacenado en silos durante meses el
acuerdo da esperanzas de que el tráfico
marítimo se recupere lo que no solo
aliviaría la inseguridad alimentaria
mundial
sino que también abriría espacio para
las cosechas entrantes para el gobierno
ucraniano la industria agrícola del país
está en juego si observamos las
solicitudes que hemos recibido vemos que
la demanda está aumentando las cifras
están creciendo ya estamos hablando de
decenas de barcos que hacen cola y
planean entrar en nuestros puertos
ahora el reto será que los buques de
propiedad privada empiecen a utilizar la
ruta regularmente con cargas por un
valor de hasta 50 millones de dólares
asegurar las preciadas mercancías en
aguas de guerra sigue siendo un
obstáculo aún no probado para las
compañías navieras